everyone welcome to your daily equation
perhaps the the single greatest
revolution in our understanding of the
universe was the move that happened in
the early part of the 20th century
taking us from the older classical view
of physics of the universe to the new
quantum perspective and within that
change the most radical shift in our
perspective came from the need to think
about the world in terms of
probabilities and indeed that is the
focus of today's daily equation I'm
going to motivate and then write down
the basic equation that articulates
mathematically this idea that the best
we can ever do is predict the likelihood
or the probability of getting one or
another outcome not the Newtonian
perspective in which you tell me how
things are today and I'll predict how
they will be tomorrow with 100%
certainty if I have 100% accurate data
and 100 in accurate calculations quantum
mechanics says that's just the wrong way
thinking about things the best you can
do is predict the probability of getting
one or another outcome all right now to
see where this all comes from let me
just put our minds back into the right
frame of mind the right perspective and
the easiest way to do that is to bring
back up if you will the the double slit
experiment the famous double slit
experiment in which in this case you're
firing little particles little electrons
at a barrier with two openings two slits
and you see that over time the
individual electrons are not landing in
two bands aligned with the two openings
which is what you would have thought
would happen but instead you're getting
many bands that are spread out along the
detector screen getting this iconic
pattern of bright regions dark regions
bright regions and dark regions and it
was realized after some consternation
that this data
is strongly hinting at the fact that
when you describe the quantum mechanical
motion of particles you need to think
about them in terms of waves why is that
well look here's a nice little image
that describes wave motion and you see
that you have water waves heading toward
a barrier with the
two openings out of each opening you
have circular water waves radiating and
because they are intermingling they're
overlapping you get this interesting
pattern right places where the peak of
one wave crosses the trough of another
cancel each other out and that's why
you've got regions of high agitation no
agitation high agitation and so forth as
you look across and on that back screen
you can see here you've got if I let
brightness on that screen and register
the agitation of the water then you've
got bright dark bright dark bright dark
just as we had with the data of
particles being fired at the screen with
the two openings and this is where the
link between particles and waves becomes
manifest same kind of data even though
it appears to be or to say it appears
not a pairs it appears to be that you
have different things being thrown at
the barrier particles in one case waves
and another same data suggests a deep
connection between them and indeed there
is a deep connection but people
struggled in the 1920s to figure out
exactly what that connection would be I
mean look you know a particle it's
something that exists at a little tiny
location in space that's what a particle
is it's like the smallest speck of
something a wave on the other hand is
completely different it's completely
spread out kind of the opposite of being
localized at one special point and so
how do you link these two ideas that
seem to be at opposite ends of that
particular spectrum and many people
weighed in and then I
1920s Aran's Schroedinger show you a
little picture of him for a little
cultural context a little visualization
here Schrodinger who is one of the
dominant figures in quantum mechanics
there's a famous equation that many of
you have asked me to talk about and I
will talk about it not today but very
soon I will Schrodinger's equation but
Schrodinger weighs him with the possible
way in which a particle might be a wave
and he says look he says maybe a
particle like an electron in reality you
think of it as a little dot but maybe
it's actually possible that you can have
a kind of smeared out electron kind of
like you know peanut butter or
mayonnaise you know you can smear it out
right
maybe an electron can be smeared out too
and that's the way an electron can be a
wave if it's not really only at a point
it can be spread out now you know it's a
natural suggestion but as people thought
about it it ran up against formidable
hurdle which is look if if an electron
really can be spread out in space then
in principle you should be able to
measure an electron and and get like a
fraction of an electron you should be
able to grab a little piece of that
smeared out electron have 1/10 of an
electron or 1/4 of an electron or 1/2 of
an electron but the data consistently
showed and shows that when you measure
an electron you always get an entire
electron the whole thing there doesn't
seem to be any sense to be made of 1/10
of an electron or 1/3 of an electron so
that interpretation of the wave
associated to a particle as just a kind
of smeared out mushy spread-out particle
doesn't work so people continue to put
forward ideas but it was actually this
guy right here
this is Max Born who is a somewhat
lesser known figure at least to the
general public when you think about the
pantheon of physicists that developed
quantum mechanic a a mild-mannered sort
of guy who would quietly
in the shadows of some of the other
Giants and in this particular case the
idea that he put forward is at the core
of quantum mechanics it is the profound
interpretive idea that comes through Max
Born where he says look what's the wave
associated with a particle like an
electron he says it's a kind of wave
that you have never encountered before
it involves an idea that seems
completely distinct from the typical
ideas that we invoke when we talk about
the motion of particles
he says the wave is a wave of
probability a wave of probability a
probability wave what does that mean
well it means that when you talk about
the motion of an electron there is a
wave and where the wave is big roughly
speaking I'll be more precise urmom
where the wave is big there's a high
probability that the electron will be
found where the wave is small there's a
smaller probability that you will find
the electron at that location and where
the wave is zero like we're the
criss-crossing waves out of the double
slit experiment where the wave from one
side can cross away from the other and
cancel each other out where the
probability wave is zero there is a zero
chance that you will find the electron
and from this interpretive scheme the
dark regions on the interference pattern
on that detector screen those would be
places where the probability waves have
canceled each other out from both
openings the probability of the particle
being found there is therefore zero and
that's why that region on the detector
screen is dark the bright regions would
be where the probability of finding the
electron is high so when you throw many
electrons over time many will land in
those locations where it's highly
probable that they will land and that's
his way of explaining the wave-like
nature of matter and also how for
instance you would use it to explain the
data in the double slit experiment let
me show you a little visual on that and
so I'm going to use a kind of blue
little wave as you see here
to represent the wave associated to a
particle like an electron a probability
wave and again where the height of the
wave is big intuitively you can think
about that as a location where it's
likely to find the particle where it's
smaller less likely and places where the
wave is zero you won't find a particle
now imagine you undertake a measurement
of the position of the electron boom and
you find it at one or another location
what does that mean well it means that
you now know where the electron is with
certainty because you've measured its
position which means the wave must spike
as we see here where all of the
probability is now centered on that
location and the wave is 0 elsewhere
because by virtue of your measurement
you know it is not located at any of
those other locations and therefore the
probability of finding it at those
locations must drop all the way to 0 now
I should say that this this process of
measuring a particle and the quantum
wave responding as I've shown in this
little visual snapping to attention and
spiking at the location where you found
the particle this is a highly
controversial part of quantum mechanics
we will come back to it this is called
the collapse of the wave function wave
function is the more precise name for
the probability wave associated to a
particle we are far from certain that
this kind of spiking this kind of
collapse actually happens in fact I
would say that most people think that it
doesn't happen in this naive way that
I've described it but for pedagogical
reasons it's it's useful to think about
things at first in this language but how
you go from the nebulous probabilities
to the definite reality that emerges
from an observation is one of the big
unsolved problems in quantum mechanics a
so-called quantum measurement problem
but putting that problem to the side the
idea if we go back to say the way people
were thinking about things in the 1920s
is after you perform the measurement and
the wave has this spike shape if you
then look away that spike shape will
kind of
melt back into this wavy probabilistic
landscape of possibilities until the
next measurement happens which causes
this fuzzy haze of possibilities to
again
snap to attention and give rise to the
single definite reality that your
observation or your measurement reveals
now look I should stress this is a
bizarre highly counterintuitive very
strange way of talking about the world
we are unused to a reality that when
we're not measuring when we're not
looking is a fuzzy haze of many
possibilities whose probabilities are
described by some quantum mechanical
undulating wave and only when we look at
the world does it then snap to attention
and have the definite qualities that we
all experience every moment of our lives
but this is the new image that is
emerging from this wave-like nature of
matter revealed today by the double slit
experiment in the hands of Max born with
this probabilistic interpretation of
what the wave actually means now let me
just put a little bit of math equation
behind this all after all this is called
your daily equation is not called your
daily animation or your daily imagery
right so let me just show you you bring
this up on the screen there we go
good okay so so first off you could
easily ask a question straight off the
bat you could say look when we have a
wave sort of a wave that looks like this
for instance there are places where the
wave is a positive and places where it's
negative so it can't literally be the
wave itself that has given you the value
of the probability because if that were
the case you'd be faced with a situation
safe having negative probabilities what
in the world would that mean and indeed
in the interpretive scheme that
born gives us it is not literally the
size of the wave at a given location
that tells you the probability it's a
little bit more complicated it's further
complicated by a word that's actually
related to complicated complex and this
is a mathematical detail that no doubt
some of you are familiar with but let me
just quickly say it the actual wave in
quantum mechanics it's often described
using the Greek letter side and we say
say Sai of X and T if we're saying doing
one-dimensional non relativistic quantum
mechanics so I only have one coordinate
over here imagine I'm just doing quantum
mechanics on the line as opposed to
space just for ease this is actually in
general as we will see when we talk
about Schrodinger's equation this is
actually a complex number
remember complex numbers involving you
know square root of -1 which is equal to
I so if it's actually a complex number
then the issue of you know having
negative probabilities is even
accentuated now because now you've got
imaginary probability so what do you do
with that so the answer is the final
answer that Bourn gives is the
probability say of finding the electron
at position X you don't set it equal to
the wave itself and let's say this is at
a given moment in time maybe I should
put that in here to avoid any confusion
you don't set it precisely directly
equal to the value of the wave rather
you take that wave and you multiply it
by its complex conjugate which we often
write as
Sai of X T squared and the beauty of
this particular combination of the wave
x its complex conjugate is that that
product is always a real number and it's
always a positive number so it's good so
our probabilities are real and positive
just like we'd want now the other thing
just as a mathematical nicety you want
it to be the case that if you
add up all of the probabilities of where
you will find a particle say at a given
moment in time and just hold the time
fixed and I'll indicate that by having a
little 0 on it
the sum of all the probabilities should
add up to 1 that's the definition really
of what probabilities are so the little
mathematical detail that's just worth
reading down here is when we talk about
these wave functions we demand that we
normalize them in such a way that if for
instance I integrate which is the
continuous version of taking a sum this
guy here at any given moment at time if
I integrate over the domain where the
particle might be it could be from minus
infinity to infinity it could be over a
finite interval that the sum of those
probabilities is equal to 1 as we have
here and I can enforce that by just
renormalizing the value of the wave
function by scaling it by a constant
value namely the square root of whatever
number this integral was if it was not
equal to 1 so if I properly normalized
my probability wave my wave function
then we come to this interpretation that
the probability of finding the particle
is given by the norm squared of whoops
the norm squared of the probability wave
at that location at that moment in time
and that is the interpretive scheme that
Max Born gives us back in the 1920s it
is a profound move again as we started
out going from the Newtonian picture
where what you see is what there is
right you describe the stuff that's out
there and it's a definite reality and
your math describes a definite reality
but Max Born together with all of the
others who are developing this quantum
picture says no what's actually out
there quantum mechanical waves those
waves evolve in a manner that as we will
discuss maybe next time maybe the time
after is given by an equation
Schrodinger's equation so we'll come to
that but these wave evolved through time
what they tell you is the probability of
finding this or that particle at this or
that location and that's the best you
can do it's not that you're missing
something and for that reason you're
relegated to talking in terms of
probabilities it's not like you know the
weatherman or flipping a coin no in the
classical sense that we just don't have
enough information to tell you exactly
what's going to happen so our ignorance
forces us into the language of
probabilities this at least in one
interpretation there are other
interpretations of these ideas maybe
I'll talk about some of them but in the
most straightforward interpretation
that's not what's going on what's going
on is the world is fundamentally
probabilistic you're not missing
anything you're not ignorant the best
you can do is describe the likelihood of
one or another outcome and it is this
quantum mechanical probability wave that
captures those probabilities
mathematically okay that's what I wanted
to talk about today this key move in
quantum mechanics to the probabilistic
equation giving us a mathematical
version of describing the world in terms
of probabilities and we'll carry on with
our discussion of quantum mechanics in
subsequent episodes but for day that's
it this is your daily equation take care
until next time